[Musik]
das monatelange warten hat ein ende es
geht los mit der impfkampagne gegen das
corona virus nebenbei bemerkt die größte
in der geschichte der bundesrepublik und
damit ganz herzlich willkommen zu
unserem live stream zu heute live und
wir schalten gleich nach hamburg zum
hospital zum heiligen geist
stellvertretend sozusagen für alle
bundesländer denn überall geht es heute
im laufe des tages los in einigen etwas
uhr in anderen bundesländern
etwas später wir sprechen mit unserem
reporter vor ort sprechen später auch
noch mit professor melanie brinkmann vom
helmholtz institut in braunschweig seas
biologin und kann uns dann einige fragen
rund um das thema impfen beantworten
zunächst ein kurzer rückblick noch
einmal auf gestern dennoch vor dem
offiziellen start wurde überraschend
schon eine 101 jährige seniorin aus
halberstadt in sachsen-anhalt geimpft
sie und rund 40 weitere heimbewohner
waren damit die ersten in ganz
deutschland die eben diesen impfstoff
bekommen haben der landkreis harz und
sachsen anhalt und ihr heim wollten
nicht warten jeder tag den wir warten
ist ein tag zu viel hieß es soweit also
der leiter der einrichtung und in knapp
drei wochen müssen die bewohner dann ein
zweites mal geimpft werden erst dann
soll der impfstoff der mainzer firma
biotec und des partners pfizer des
us-partners die volle wirkung haben auch
darüber werden wir dann später noch mal
sprechen über den impfstoff und über die
wirkung aber wir schalten jetzt zunächst
nach hamburg zu meinem kollegen ralf
zimmermann von siewert mit weiteren
informationen
ok ich sehe dass wir das bild aus
hamburg auch gerade schon sehen wir sie
in den ersten bürgermeister peter
tschentscher selbst mediziner der auch
vor ort ist bei der impfung und wenn ich
das richtig sehe dann geht es auch
gleich los ich habe leider noch keinen
namen bezüglich der dame die sich da
offensichtlich impfen lassen wird das
können wir vielleicht gleich noch
nachreichen
wie gesagt unser reporter ist in hamburg
ist vor ort und wird auch gleich noch
mal mit uns sprechen und uns weitere
details geben können so das sieht so aus
als ob da jetzt die vorbereitungen
getroffen wurden für die erste impfung
so hat die kurze frage sprechen wir nein
wir gucken noch mal auf das bild
so ja also vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz
allgemeine informationen für sie oder
euch liebe user ihr habt das mit
sicherheit auch schon gehört also es
gibt die ersten mobilen teams die heute
unterwegs sind und der schwerpunkt liegt
natürlich bei den personen über 80 jahre
vor allem auch in dem senioren
residenzen die beginnen ich weiß nicht
ob da jetzt schon den ersten pixar gab
naja also einzelheiten vor ort bzw
die genaueren kenntnisse hat dazu
sicherlich mein kollege vor ort reifen
sondern von sie verdienen ich jetzt rufe
ralf da ist er schon herzlich willkommen
bei uns in der sendung hat was haben wir
da jetzt gerade gesehen vielleicht noch
mal ein kurzer überblick über das
geschehen vor ort also was wir gerade
gesehen haben kann ich auch nicht sagen
weil ich es auch dass sie ihm kann ich
stehe hier draußen vor dem impfzentrum
einem spital zum heiligen geist das
hospital zum heiligen geist ist die
größte pflegeeinrichtung an einem ort in
hamburg 1200 menschen alte menschen
leben hier
und davon werden wie praktisch alle
jetzt in den nächsten drei tagen hier
geimpft
ich will mal ganz kurz vielleicht gehen
wir da noch einmal hin darf ich sie mal
ganz kurz fragen wie wichtig ist für sie
im punkt jetzt wollen wir haben
eigentlich keine bisher keine risse dass
er leute dagegen sind sondern das ist
die resonanz ist sehr sehr groß ist das
für sie jetzt die möglichkeit sozusagen
rauszukommen aus der einsamkeit
[Musik]
wir dürfen hier raus wir sind hier
normale mieter und wir dürfen raus und
wird aber wir natürlich mit sämtlichen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen und so weiter
aber wir können uns frei bewegen dürfen
einkaufen gehen wir können hier
spazieren gehen können wir auch hier
meistens so in dieser ecke werden ich
habe zum beispiel weder bus noch bahn
noch sonst etwas also ich will das sind
jetzt zwei damen die tatsächlich hier
noch selbstständig wohnen aber es gibt
ganz viele die eben auch in den häusern
stationär aufgenommen sind die werden
heute als erste hier geimpft auch die
angestellten aus dem hospital zum
heiligen geist werden geimpft 1500
menschen in den nächsten drei tagen das
ist eines der altenheime die in hamburg
jetzt als erstes dran sind
es werden andere altenheimer ab morgen
auch heute auch schon ein anderes werden
auch heute schon von diesem mobilen impf
teams die drinnen die impfungen
vornehmen werden hier geimpft mit dem
wirkstoff gegen kuwait 19 und die
erwartungen hier ich habe vorhin auch
mit einer anderen alten dame gesprochen
ist natürlich dass sie jetzt aus der
einsamkeit herausfinden dass dieses
abgeschirmt sein was hier zwar sehr gut
organisiert ist aber eben sehr sehr
mühsam ist für die alten menschen dass
das jetzt aufführt und natürlich auch
das corona hier gestoppt wird denn es
gibt hier in dieser anlage gibt es
zurzeit auch 20 offizielle die behandelt
werden müssen und menschen schwer
erkrankt sind zum teil einige auch in
krankenhäuser verlegt werden mussten
ja vielleicht gibt es eine frage
christopher von der euch die euch
interessiert ich kann noch viel erzählt
über dieses hospital die erste die jetzt
drinnen geimpft wird ich weiß nicht ob
man das bild sehen kann ist karin
sievers eine 84-jährige alte dame und
danach folgen dann weitere ich habe hier
lauter namen auf dem zettel
das alter ist jenseits der 80 natürlich
es werden ja die über 80-jährigen jetzt
speziell auch in den
altenpflegeeinrichtungen erst mal
geimpft in den ersten im ersten in der
ersten prioritätsstufe sozusagen
und dafür wird man viele tage brauchen
das zentrale im
zentrum in hamburg dass es hier
natürlich auch gibt dem messegelände
das wird tatsächlich erst im neuen jahr
in betrieb genommen werden es wird am
dienstag nochmal ein probelauf dort
geben aber die angestellten die in
diesem zentrum tätig sind das sind ja
leute aus hausärztlichen praxen aus
heino praxen usw
die sind auch jetzt teile dieser mobilen
impf teams wie es eben auch hier heute
unterwegs sind hier alleine hier auf dem
gelände für diese 1500 menschen sind
heute 15 teams am start da werden
natürlich auch viel da wird noch viel
geübt da wird noch viel geprobt den
abläufen usw
das ist ja alles überhaupt nicht geübt
und eingeübt sondern man hat im grunde
die weihnachtstage jetzt benutzt um
überhaupt ist einigermaßen so
vorzubereiten dass es funktioniert also
zum beispiel musste es
einverständniserklärungen geben von
jedem einzelnen jeder einzelne muss
seine einverständniserklärung geben das
ist gerade in den alten und pflegeheim
ein besonders schwieriges unterfangen
weil die menschen zum teil ja dement
sind zum teil so pflegebedürftig sind
dass sie das selbst gar nicht mehr
entscheiden können das heißt angehörige
das tun müssen
das musste zum teil schriftlich
eingeholt werden wenn die angehörigen
nicht direkt hier vor ort leben also
auch das ein sehr umständliches
schwieriges verfahren das aber
offensichtlich ganz gut gelaufen ist
jedenfalls hier nach dem was mir heute
morgen von der heimleitung und den
zuständigen erzählt worden ist also es
war ein in einen weihnachten im
ausnahmezustand insofern als alle im
grunde gearbeitet haben und sich mühe
gegeben haben um diesen impfstart heute
am 27 dezember überhaupt möglich zu
machen
später noch mal nach hamburg zurück auch
der erste bürgermeister peter
tschentscher den wir vorhin schon im
bild gesehen haben wird sich auch noch
mal äußern das dann später wollen jetzt
aber schalten nach braunschweig zu
professor melanie brinkmann leiterin des
helmholtz zentrums für
infektionsforschung eben dort einen
schönen guten tag und herzlich
willkommen frau professor brinkmann ja
wie ist ihre gefühlslage eigentlich an
diesem tag es wird ja verglichen mit der
mondlandung hin und wieder ist ihre
stimmung ähnlich
also ich muss sagen es ist wirklich ein
sehr berührender morgen
diese damen die jetzt schon geimpft
wurde gestern und heute zu sehen und ja
die ganze entwicklung wenn man mal
zurückblickt anfang des jahres ist ein
unbekannter erreger auf der welt
aufgetaucht und tauchte auch sehr frühe
deutschland auf und ein paar monate
später haben wir einen impfstoff und
griffen ihn tatsächlich schon und ich
muss sagen dass dieser impfstoff
tatsächlich auch meine größten
erwartungen weit übertroffen hat ich bin
angetan von seiner hohen wirksamkeit und
absolut begeistert wie schnell er jetzt
auch von den offiziellen stellen
zugelassen wurde
sie sprechen die geschwindigkeit des
verfahrens an darüber wollen wir
natürlich gleich auch noch sprechen was
mag den einen oder anderen geben bei dem
dieses verfahren und auch die
geschwindigkeit vielleicht unbehagen
oder auch skepsis ausgelöst dazu gleich
noch mal mehr wie lange wird es denn
jetzt ihrer einschätzung nach dauern bis
also die pandemie sozusagen in
deutschland in den griff bekommen werden
kann also wir haben ja einige zahlen
schon gehört also im jahr 2020 in diesem
jahr sollen noch etwa 1,3 millionen
dosen ausgeliefert werden im januar dann
700.000 pro woche und
gesundheitsminister sparen sagte dass er
damit rechnet dass bis märz etwa zehn
millionen dosen des baxter impfstoffes
zumindest ausgeliefert werden können
also wie es ihrer vorstellung nach da
der grobe zeitplan wann kommt man da
signifikant voran bei der bekämpfung
eben der pandemie ja es ist schwierig
jetzt zu erwarten so dass es unmöglich
zu erwarten dass wir im frühjahr schon
ein wenig wesentlichen effekt auf die
pandemie sehen werden das bedeutet
länger dauern
denn die impfdosen die wir zur verfügung
haben werden die sind zum einen
limitiert und das heißt ja auch dass ich
heißt ja auch dass nicht nur ich brauche
ja pro person zwei dieser impfdosen um
die immunität zu erreichen die jetzt in
den klinischen studien erreicht wurde
von daher entsprechend also zehn
millionen impfdosen nur fünf millionen
geimpften und das ist erst
nur ein heißer tropfen ein tropfen auf
dem heißen stein wenn ich jetzt ins
frühe blicke ich werde einen effekt
sehen auf die sterberate in der
deutschen bevölkerung zum ende des
jahres hin wenn viele menschen die zu
der hohen risikogruppe gehören geimpft
sind aber das ist eine logistische
meisterleistung allein dadurch dass ich
zwei impfdosen benötige auch dadurch
dass der impfstoff bei einer sehr
niedrigen temperatur gelagert werden
muss und wir sollten auch weiterhin
unseren blick auf andere impfstoffe
anwerfen ich hoffe dass wir noch viele
weitere impfstoffe haben werden dies auf
den markt schaffen die zugelassen werden
bleibt dann einfach mehr möglichkeiten
haben und auch mehr impfdosen
denn je schneller wir impfen desto
schneller sehen wir auch einen effekt
auf die ausbreitung des virus klar also
es gibt unterschiedliche impfstoffe
vielleicht aber zunächst noch mal der
blick auf den aktuell verimpft impfstoff
den wollen wir unseren zuschauern auch
noch mal ein bisschen näher bringen wie
dieser m rna impfstoff eigentlich wird
einzelheiten dazu jetzt noch einmal in
einem kurzen beitrag bei montech
moderner und die neue impfstoff klasse
noch nie zuvor gab es einen zugelassenen
gen basierten m rna impfstoff bei einem
gen basierten impfstoff bekommt der
körper nur die notwendigen
erbgutinformationen des erregers den
bauplan gewissermaßen mit dem einige
wenige zellen im körper die proteine des
erregers selbst produzieren auf die
reagiert dann das immunsystem und bildet
zum schutz antikörper ein prinzip das
die wissenschaft kennt auch wenn es noch
nie außerhalb von studien zum tragen kam
also die wirkweise von emma impfstoffen
wird seit 20 jahren erforscht das ist
ein sehr gut sehr gut studiert das
molekül und ich würde sagen dass emma
impfstoffe wissenschaftlich sehr viel
besser verstanden sind als viele andere
impfstoff klassen die heute schon
zugelassen sind
die befürchtung vieler menschen die neue
impfstoff klasse könnte das menschliche
erbgut beeinflussen
diese sorge sei unbegründet erinnerung
rufen sie nicht in der lage unsere
genommen zu verändern
die impfstoffe kommen viele fragen
bleiben wie lange wirkt eine impfung
verhindert sie eine weitergabe des virus
antworten gibt es wohl frühestens in
einigen monaten nach weiteren impfungen
also einige fragen sind damit noch
verbunden wir sprechen mit melanie
brinkmann virologin genau und wie sorge
ich habe gerade noch eine kleine
information aufs ohr bekommen die frage
aber auch die jetzt hier in diesem
beitrag er auftauchte wie schnell tritt
der schutz bei einem geimpften nach der
ersten impfung ein also wir haben ja
schon gelernte sind zwei impfungen
eigentlich erforderlich was passiert
nach der ersten spritze und nach der
zweiten wie lange hält das teilen sie
meint lang die immunität danach richtig
wenn man zwei impfdosen bekommen hat das
wissen wir noch nicht genau
das ist eine der großen fragen die noch
im raum steht und dass das lernen dann
weitere studien zeigen natürlich dass
mir leid ich muss noch mal ganz kurz
unterbrechen sommer aber wir gehen doch
nochmal aktuell
sie müssen entschuldigen aufgrund der
live situation müssen wir doch noch mal
sehr hamburg gehen mit den dort haben
wir eine dame die offensichtlich schon
gehen worden ist
dann sage ich ihm
rossi wird man einen wunderbaren sohn
sagen offen und wenn sie nicht verstand
und sie weiß vielleicht eine frage
freuen sich nur dass sich die erde um
verständnis eine frage an frau etwas
kosten zu lassen und jetzt habe war dass
es ihr nicht wehgetan hat das ist ja
schon mal eine erste erkenntnis die
frage jetzt noch mal an die regie
sprechen wir weiter mit frau professor
brinkmann oder hören
wir bleiben dran
ja sehr geehrte damen und herren wir
haben heute in hamburg mit den ersten
impfungen begonnen sie wissen dass der
impfstoff gestern hier in hamburg
angekommen ist er ist sehr sorgfältig zu
handhaben
man muss wissen dass der impfstoff und
die studien unter sehr strengen
bedingungen durchgeführt worden sind die
jetzt eingehalten werden müssen
das bedeutet dass dieser impfstoff eben
nicht wie sonst über die normale
hausarzt praxis eingesetzt werden kann
soll man braucht speziell geschulte
teams die jetzt vorbereitet sind in
hamburg zunächst in denen senioren und
pflegeeinrichtungen den ersten impfstoff
einzusetzen diese wahl dass man mit den
senioreneinrichtungen beginnt und dem
personal in diesen einrichtungen beruht
auf der erkenntnis dass wir hier um uns
besonders natürlich bemühen diejenigen
zu schützen die besonders schwer
erkranken können oder die eben einen
besonderen infektionsrisiko ausgesetzt
es wird so sein dass wir jetzt woche für
woche impfstoff dieses herstellers
bekommen
solange es keinen anderen impfstoff gibt
wird dieser impfstoff eben von diesem
speziell geschulten teams auch
eingesetzt einerseits dezentral in den
einrichtungen andererseits aber auch in
dem impfzentrum das vorbereitet ist
sobald größere mengen an impfstoff zur
verfügung stehen
die dann auch zentral einzusetzen es
geht uns ja darum möglichst schnell
möglichst viele personen zu impfen
deswegen war es gut dass alles
vorbereitet war ich danke noch mal
ausdrücklich allen die in dieser
vorbereitung beteiligt waren das ist
allen voran die kassenärztliche
vereinigung in hamburg bei heinrich der
heute auch die erste impfung praktisch
durchgeführt hat hat mit seinen teams
sehr viel gedankliche vorarbeit
geleistet ist gestern noch wurde sehr
präzise
beobachtet wie der impfstoff wirklich
sich verhält wenn er aufgelöst wenn er
verdünnt wird wenn er in die spritzen
aufgenommen wird das alles ist wirklich
fachkundige arbeit die hier geleistet
wird und das wird unterstützt von den
stellen der stadt dem gegebenen institut
in hamburg den fachleuten der behörde
für soziales und gesundheit und insofern
ist es wirklich ein gutes zeichen dass
wir in einer lage sind die historisch
nicht neu ist
wir sind in einer stiftung hospital zum
heiligen geist die fast 800 jahre alt
ist die also schon viele epidemien und
pandemien historisch erlebt hat aber zum
ersten mal kann man aktiv in dieser
situation etwas tun und ich bin froh
dass es uns in deutschland in europa
weltweit gelingt jetzt der pandemie die
stirn zu bieten und sie schritt für
schritt zu überwinden und damit auch
dann endgültig in eine normale situation
zurück zu kommen
es ist viel zu früh jetzt über
lockerungen nachzudenken wir sind in
einer noch sehr ernsten infektions lage
wir werden jetzt die zwei drei wochen
über die weihnachts und silvester tage
ja erst einmal uns ansehen müssen idee
in deutschland ist diese zeit zu nutzen
um eine zu einer deutlichen verminderung
der infektionszahlen zu kommen und im
hintergrund beginnt jetzt die impfung in
deutschland aber sie wird noch eine
weile dauern bis ein ausreichender
schutz vor infektionen in deutschland
gewährleistet ist und insofern hängt
jetzt davon ab welche weiteren
impfstoffe zu welchem zeitpunkt zur
verfügung stehen
es sind mehrere aussichtsreiche
impfstoffkandidaten im
zulassungsverfahren so dass wir durchaus
zuversichtlich sein können dass dies
nicht der einzige impfstoff bleiben wird
aber es ist ein wichtiger erster schritt
ein anfang um das zu erreichen was ja
die pandemie strategie in deutschland
ausmacht die infektionsgefahr blick
niedrig zu halten und möglichst wenig
erkrankungen und vor allem eine
überlastung des gesundheitswesens zu
verhindern
aber auf der anderen seite eben auch
zeit zu überbrücken bis dann wirklich
mit einer impfung ein endgültiger schutz
vor der erkrankung vielleicht sogar vor
der übertragung der erkrankung eintritt
das wäre ja insgesamt ein großer erfolg
nachfragen nehmen wir gleich gern
gesammelt
zunächst auch von meiner seite einen
schönen guten tag ich freue mich sehr
dass wir heute sein können im hospital
zum heiligen geist in hamburg auch mein
dank richtet sich an die vielen menschen
die wissen spät in die nacht weiß ich
heute alles vorbereitet haben damit wir
hier mit den impfungen beginnen können
das begann mit dem gegen name des
impfstoffs gestern sehr professionell
der sortierung der vorbereitung der
portionierung wir werden hier heute mit
20 impft teams vor ort sein um allen
menschen eine schutzimpfung anzubieten
die einen möchten das betrifft die
bewohnerinnen und die bewohner und das
betrifft aber auch das paar
mal von pflegeeinrichtungen so machen
wir in den nächsten tagen weiter und
sind ja noch zwei weitere lieferungen
lieferungen vor silvester avisiert
worden bis wir dann anfang januar auch
unser impfzentrum in betrieb nehmen
können wo wir dann hoffentlich vielen
menschen eine schutzimpfung anbieten
können
ich bin besonders deswegen sehr dankbar
und deswegen ist es auch ein guter tag
weil jede schutzimpfung die jemand
bekommt dazu beitragen kann dass ein
schwerer krankheitsverlauf vermieden
wird sie erreicht sozusagen damit
schritt für schritt dass es uns gelingt
den weg aus der pandemie zu finden und
das ist etwas sehr gutes und wir haben
diesen tag das können sie uns glauben
sehr lange erwartet sowohl die menschen
die heute hier bereit sind sich impfen
zu lassen wie auch die mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter in der altenpflege und
der krankenpflege sie wissen wir haben
jeden tag noch eine hohe zahl an
neuinfektionen und weiterhin leisten
jeden tag viele menschen vieles um die
pandemie folgen entsprechend abzufedern
ich möchte mich ganz ganz besonders hier
nochmal bei den mitarbeitern hier im
hause bedanken die viel geleistet haben
in den letzten tagen beim thema
aufklärung die geholfen haben das
aufklärungsbogen verteilt werden die
einverständniserklärung eingeholt haben
die erste fragen beantwortet haben um so
zu ermöglichen dass wir heute schon
viele menschen impfen können vielen dank
allen dafür und allen die im moment tag
und nacht viel dafür tun dass wir die
pandemie so gut es geht einheben könnten
gut
soweit also die statements von peter
tschentscher dem ersten bürgermeister
von hamburg und von melanie neonazis die
zuständige senatorin wir waren aber im
gespräch mit frau professor melanie
brinkmann und wir waren bei der frage
stehen geblieben wie sieht es aus mit
der immunität wann ist diese erreicht
nach der ersten beziehungsweise zweiten
spritze wie lange hält diese überhaupt
an
ich habe sie in ihrer antwort
unterbrochen entschuldigung noch mal
dafür also die klinischen studien haben
mit zwei impfdosen gearbeitet das heißt
man wurde einmal geimpft dann hat man 21
tage ungefähr gewartet und dann das
zweite marke impft und
dann hat man eben den effekt gemessen
den dieser im stoff hat und der lag ja
unheimlich hoch der lag über 90 prozent
und das ist wirklich liegt wirklich
deutlich über allen erwartungen die die
meisten von uns hatten und es ist ein
großartiger erfolg
jetzt kann man dann hat man auch
tatsächlich gesehen dass die erste
impfung auch schon einen gewissen schutz
zu bieten scheint aber dazu gibt es noch
keine studie
und die könnte man tatsächlich jetzt ja
durchführen das wäre nicht verkehrt und
hätte man einfach mehr impfstoff für
alle arbeiten muss erst durchgeführt
werden um da wirklich ein klares klare
aussage treffen zu können
frau professor brinkmann wir an dem ja
auch immer gerne unsere user mit in die
sendung cola erbse in spe schreibt über
youtube oder meldet sich zumindest auf
diesem wege die firma die den impfstoff
hergestellt hat warnt vor gravierenden
nebenwirkungen
deshalb wird das nicht erwähnt ist dem
überhaupt so dass das nicht erwähnt wird
also das land habe ich noch von nicht
gravierenden nebenwirkungen gehört also
ich habe bislang überhaupt noch gar
nicht zu nebenwirkungen gehört es gibt
einige wenige patienten die eine
allergische reaktion aufweisen das sind
aber sehr sehr wenige man muss immer
bedenken wie viele menschen schon
geimpft werden aktuell england hat ja
angefangen und da sind schon viele
tausend menschen geimpft worden und bei
nur ganz wenigen wurden nebenwirkungen
gezeigt die diese allergische reaktion
und keiner davon hat dadurch einen
schaden hervor getragen es ist ja häufig
dass man allergische reaktionen hat wenn
man etwas ist oder ein neues medikament
nimmt es können immer passieren
das ist für mich überhaupt kein grund
zur sorge was für mich wichtig ist es zu
betonen die studien die durchgeführt
wurden die dazu geführt haben dass die
impfstoffe zugelassen worden ich rede
jetzt von moderner und von dem biontech
im stoff die wurden mit so vielen
menschen durchgeführt wie das noch nie
getan wurde
vor einer für einen impfstoff und es
sind kaum nebenwirkungen beobachtet
worden
nebenwirkungen traten auf direkt
zu beginn der impfung und die sind
völlig normal dass menschen auf den
impfstoff erst einmal reagieren mit
leichtem fieber oder mit
erkältungssymptomen aber das ist völlig
normal und auch nur ein zeichen dafür
dass der körper erkannt hat ist es etwas
fremdes in meinem körper und ich muss
dagegen jetzt eine immunantwort aufbaut
ist das prinzip der impfung wir sind
also nicht mit dem echten erreger
konfrontiert der uns sehr krank machen
kann sondern nur mit einem kleinen teil
des erregers und das reicht um unserem
immunsystem vorzugaukeln
das ist tatsächlich etwas tun muss gegen
einen eindringlingen und eine gute
immunantwort hervorruft vielleicht kann
ich ja aus kurz noch mal darauf eingehen
entschuldigung was diese m rna
impfstoffe nun besonders ausmacht wo
liegt deren wirksamkeit beziehungsweise
können sie die sorgen der menschen auch
zerstreuen die sagen na ja dadurch
könnte eventuell das gehen das erbgut
verändert werden das ist ja auch eine
frage die vor einem film schon
angesprochen messe war
wenn ich mal ganz ehrlich sein soll ich
wüsste wirklich gerne wird dieses
gerücht gestreut hat dass die mrsa sich
in das genom integrieren kann das ist
wirklich völliger quatsch
und ich würde es hier wirklich gern
einmal ganz klar damit aufräumen das
kann nicht passieren
die m rna kann nicht in unsere dna
unserer kinder rum integrieren das ist
technisch einfach nicht möglich und es
gibt überhaupt keine wissenschaftliche
evidenz dafür dass es passieren kann und
warum kann das nicht passieren weil
diese m rna sich nicht dort aufhält wo
sich unser genom aufhält in unseren
zellen und mrsa sind etwas was wir
tagtäglich selber produzieren und von
dieser m rna bildende dann proteine die
lebenswichtig sind für unser überleben
für unseren körper und deshalb ist
dieser m rna impfstoff tatsächlich ein
sehr sicherer in stoff und ich bin
wirklich begeistert dass er ein so hoher
wirksamkeit zeigt
also ich gebe den menschen ja wirklich
nur einen kleinen abschnitt dass ein
paar buchstaben enthält und daraufhin
löse ich diese sehr effektive
immunantwort aus das ist für mich
faszinierend dass es so gut funktioniert
hat und ich halte diesen impfstoff für
sehr sicher
und wenn sie mich jetzt fragen würden ob
ich den selber neben wird nehmen würde
diesen impfstoff den würde ich ohne mit
der wimper zu zucken dauert
wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen bis sie
dann auch stehe leider sehr schlanker
sehr weit hinten
da die am schluss ist meine eltern
sofort damit impfen lassen das sind
einmal jahren als beruhigende worte
jedenfalls auch was sie gesagt haben
zudem m rna impfstoff generell delicious
fragt über youtube wieso weiß man nicht
sicher ob jemand der den impfstoff
verabreicht bekommt danach andere mit
scoop.it infizieren kann
ja das ist eine sehr gute frage darauf
war die studie von montech nicht
ausgelegt und er hat recht mit der frage
das ist etwas was wir unbedingt noch
adressieren müssen und dazu brauchen wir
eine weitere studie die darauf ausgelegt
ist genau zu schauen können die menschen
die mit dem impfstoff behandelt wurden
weiterhin zulassen das virus sich in
ihnen vermehrt also dir der ideale
impfstoff der erlaubt den virus gar
nicht erst groß fuß zu fassen unserem
körper der idealen stoff induziert ein
so potent immunantwort dass das virus so
bald es auch unsere schleimhäute gelangt
sofort einen auf den deckel bekommt und
gar nicht erst fuß fassen kann und sich
vermehren kann
nun gibt es auch im monat folgen die
nicht ganz so potent sind die aber
immerhin noch verhindern können dass wir
schwer krank werden weil sie das virus
relativ früh in seine schranken weisen
können also unsere immunantwort und das
ist bei diesem impfstoff auf jeden fall
der fall denn es wurde ja danach
geschaut ob er verhindern kann dass
menschen schwere symptome aufweisen und
das kann er auf jeden fall
und nun brauchen wir eine weitere studie
die noch zeigen kann auch dieser
impfstoff auch so potent ist das auch
verhindern kann das virus sich überhaupt
in unserem körper vermehren kann und wir
dann natürlich noch weitere menschen
anstecken können also ausgeschlossen ist
es nicht es ist nur noch nicht erforscht
worden in diesem sinne richtig dass
miranda den siviglia fragt hilft die
impfung auch wenn man bereits erkrankte
ist
nein dann kommt es zu spät also dass ein
impfstoff muss vorher schon appliziert
worden sein das war wirklich vor der
infektion schützen kann denn es dauert
eine zeit lang nach der impfung bis
unsere immunantwort ausgebildet ist
bis sie vollständig ausgewählt ist das
dauert zwei bis drei wochen
und in der zeit wäre es dann nicht
unbedingt haben wir noch keinen schutz
vor der richtigen infektion
vielen dank bis hierhin eine häufig
gestellte frage unserer user ist wie sie
erfahren wann sie dran sind wer ist
überhaupt wann dran auch in dieses
fragen dickicht wollen wir noch mal ein
bisschen licht bringen wie ist die
reihenfolge dieser aktuellen
impfkampagne ausgelegt dazu noch mal ein
paar einzelheiten geimpft werden soll in
mehreren stufen zuallererst sind
menschen über 80 jahre und pflegeheim
bewohner an der reihe
auch medizinisches personal mit sehr
hohem ansteckungsrisiko gehört dazu
etwa in notaufnahmen und solche mit
engen kontakt zu cupid von zehn
infizierten zur stufe zwei zellen ältere
zwischen 70 und 79 jahren menschen mit
demenz oder einer geistigen behinderung
die in einrichtungen leben auch die
hausärzte gehören dazu und enge
kontaktpersonen von pflegebedürftigen
und schwangeren zur stufe 3 gehören
personen ab 60 jahren und solche mit
erhöhtem risiko für einen schweren
verlauf einer corona infektion auch
mitarbeiter besonders relevanter berufe
zählen dazu zum beispiel polizei
feuerwehr und erzieher
zuletzt kommen alle anderen menschen
unter 60 jahren und ohne vorerkrankungen
an die reihe
ja so weit also nochmal die reihenfolge
so wie sie vorgesehen ist aber wir
wollen noch einmal gehen nach hamburg zu
meinem kollegen ralf zimmermann von
siewert denn der hat dort einen
gesprächspartner wenn ich richtig
informiert bin ralf bitte schwören wer
ist bei dir ja noch ist eigentlich
herkommt sofort rauris hamburgs erster
bürgermeister das bild hier bisschen
heftig zu weil hier natürlich eine menge
journalisten und hamburger presse ist
kommt jetzt aber diese sekunde hoffe ich
raus und wird uns ein paar fragen noch
beantworten
er hat gerade ist ja noch mal gesagt
worden wie wichtig diese impfkampagne
jetzt ist auch wie wichtig es ist dass
die menschen tatsächlich daran
teilnehmen ganz interessant war auch der
leiter des infozentrums hier in hamburg
der vor ein paar tagen gesagt hat wir
wollen das auch sehr professionell nach
außen hin wirken lassen damit die leute
einfach vertrauen kriegen damit die
leute die zweifel äußern an dem impfen
dass die im grunde widerlegt werden
herr bürgermeister wir sind live drauf
schönen guten tag vielen dank dass sie
sich die minuten eben noch jedes stück
ist dieses jetzt tatsächlich als signal
auch gesellschaft das ist ein signal
dass wir jetzt wirklich zuversichtlich
sein können dass wir etwas aktiv gegen
die korona pandemie tun können denn die
impfung schützt ja denjenigen der dienst
wird vor einer schweren erkrankung und
jede impfung schützt natürlich auch das
gesundheitswesen vor einer überlastung
das sind ja die beiden
ziele die wir verfolgen das wir eben
erkrankung verhindern und unser
gesundheitswesen schützen und damit auch
einer anderen erkrankung weiter gut
behandelt werden können
hier in dieser altenpflegeeinrichtung
dass er einer der großen in hamburg hat
mir gerade eine alte frau gesagt für uns
ist es der wehr der pfad raus aus der
einsamkeit in der wir jetzt noch lange
gelebt haben auch gerade jetzt über
weihnachten aber das ist hier nur ein
erster schritt die alten menschen die
gebrechlichen menschen jetzt als erstes
das ist ein erster schritt aber es ist
ein wichtiger schritt
gerade die soziale isolierung in den
pflege- und senioreneinrichtungen sind
ja ein problem wenn wir infektionsschutz
betreiben müssen und viele ältere
menschen hier haben wir gerade für
richtig dass sie heiligabend tatsächlich
dann auch alleine verbracht haben
vielleicht telefoniert aber eben nicht
so wie sonst
und wenn wir eben gerade diese sehr sehr
für krone anfälligen personengruppen
geimpft haben dann wird es eben auch
einfacher im handling dieser situation
in den einrichtungen dazu kommt ja das
personal das ja auch geimpft werden soll
im ersten schritt weil es immer wieder
auch verleger infektionen nicht nur über
besucherinnen und besucher sondern auch
über das personal in die einrichtung
trotzdem da nochmal die nachfrage diese
dieses erste generation der wohlhabenden
gruppe über 80 jetzt erstmal wird ja
noch keinen großen effekt haben auf das
gesamte infektionsgeschehen in der
bevölkerung also mit erleichterungen
oder lockerungen ist in den nächsten
tagen wochen zu rechnen oder nicht
zurecht einen so kurzen zeiträumen kann
es zu diesen zu diesem schutz vor der
pandemie nicht kommen wir beginnen jetzt
schrittweise sobald impfstoff zur
verfügung ist person zu impfen
und damit steigt natürlich die impfrate
aber sie wird natürlich zu anfang nur
sehr langsam steigen
das kann sich aber verbessern wenn
weitere impfstoffe zugelassen werden
die ja schon in der zulassung sind die
dann aber auch einfacher zu handhaben
sind sobald wir also impfstoffe haben
die über die normale hausarzt praxis
eingesetzt werden
dann wird es eben auch schneller gehen
diejenigen zu impfen die eine impfung
bekommen möchten gerade aus meiner regie
changer wir haben noch ein zwei fragen
von usern von tatsächlich zuschauern die
noch mal wissen wollen
bestimmte sachen christopher sagt auch
mal schnell was gibt's da die frage die
oft gestellt wird ist wie jetzt genau
die reihenfolge aussieht beziehungsweise
zum beispiel wie das vielleicht jetzt
auch in hamburg organisiert ist wer
kriegt bescheid wie wird das gemacht wer
ist wann dran
können sie das sagen sie sind peter
tschentscher ist ja nicht nur erster
bürgermeister er ist auch ehemaliger
labormediziner also erst die medizin ist
schon geschlagen glaube ich darf man
sagen wie ist die reihenfolge wie wird
das jetzt genau gemacht wie wird jeder
informiert der jetzt dran ist viele alte
menschen habe ich auch schon erlebt
wissen noch gar nicht da muss ich nicht
jetzt melden oder werde ich kontaktiert
wie funktioniert das
zunächst einmal sind wir ja über die
einrichtung jetzt aktiv das heißt in den
einrichtungen wird das
informationsangebot hingegen gibt es
auch aufklärungsgespräche werden
diejenigen die bereit sind sich impfen
zu lassen dann registriert und
angemeldet und dann wird je nach
einrichtung die anzahl der personen
ermittelt die geimpft werden kann und
dann kommt an im team und impfte jenigen
die dafür vorgesehen sind das ist
zunächst einmal etwas was organisiert
wird wo also man sich nicht selber jetzt
meldet später wird es dann so sein wenn
diese breiter verfügbaren impfstoffe zur
verfügung stehen dass man dann sich wie
bei jeder normalen impfung dann auch bei
seinem haus als melden kann
aber momentan geht es streng nach den
vorschriften und den empfehlungen der
im kommission es sind ja experten die
festgelegt haben nach fachlichen
kriterien welche personengruppen als
erstes geimpft werden weil sie am
dringendsten eine impfung benötigen
und deswegen ist das derzeit noch ein
organisiertes system bedanke mich bei
hamburgs erster bürgermeister peter
tschentscher vielen dank
und ja damit geben wir erstmal wieder
zurück nach mainz aus dem imf aus der
von der ersten impfung hier in hamburg
im hospital zum heiligen geist ralf
vielen dank für diese eindrücke und
informationen dankeschön hamburg wir
sprechen weiter mit frau professor
melanie brinkmann vom helmholtz institut
virologin und frau bringt man auch eine
viel gestellte frage zb von sylvia
steffan aktiv der aktuelle impfstoff
stoff auch gegen die neue virus
mutationen die ja doch für einige
irritationen oder beziehungsweise auch
fürsorge daneben gesorgt hat die bereits
eben auch in deutschland angekommen ist
gibt es informationen dazu wie ist ihre
einschätzung
ja also die wissenschaftliche
einschätzung dazu ist dass es höchst
wahrscheinlich ist dass dieser impfstoff
dagegen noch wirkt gegen diese neue
mutante die aufgetaucht ist
aber es sollte schon auch ein weckruf
sein und uns daran erinnern dass wir uns
auf unseren lorbeeren nicht ausruhen
dürfen wir müssen auch weiterhin wachsam
bleiben und unser überwachungssystem
deutlich verbessern hier in deutschland
um das neue virus mutanten ausschau zu
halten und sie rechtzeitig zu
identifizieren denn es kann schon
passieren dass es noten gibt bei denen
der jetzige impfstoff nicht mehr greift
wenn das so ist wissen wir nicht die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist gering aber es
kann sehr wohl passieren und dann haben
wir natürlich ein großes problem
dazu muss man sagen dass gerade in bezug
auf diese möglichkeit dass die viren
sich verändern eine evolution
durchlaufen
dass wir gerade im hinblick darauf ganz
ganz stark weiterhin die
infektionszahlen unter kontrolle haben
müssen und das müssen wir in allen
ländern am besten weltweit
wir müssen weltweit das
infektionsgeschehen kontrollieren
denn je mehr infektion wird zulauf zu
lassen desto höher ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es zu solchen
mutation kommt und die sich dann
natürlich auch ausbreiten weil wir ja
irgendwann wieder als normale leben zu
lassen wollen wir wollen wieder reisen
ja und wenn einzelne länder
infektionsgeschehen und kontrolliert
laufen lassen dann kann es sehr gut sein
dass ich dann virus mutanten die sich
durchsetzen die vielleicht infektiöser
sind tatsächlich dann auch wieder
weltweit verbreiten das heißt wir müssen
weiterhin eine strategie fahren bis ihr
eine ruhezeit der bevölkerung weltweit
geimpft haben die eine niedrige instanz
der infektion
das war ja in einem ganz wichtigen punkt
den sie da jetzt eben auch gerade
ansprechen der derzeitige stadt daun
dauert noch roundabout 14 tage am 5
januar berät dann die politik noch mal
darüber wie es danach weitergehen soll
nach dem was sie jetzt gerade gesagt
haben wie ist ihre einschätzung wie wird
es danach weitergehen wie darf es danach
weitergehen sehen sie chancen für eine
lockerung
es ist schwer zu sagen wie sich die zahl
jetzt entwickeln es kommt ganz darauf an
wie die menschen sich jetzt verhalten
über die feiertage und je weniger
kontakte wir haben in dieser zeit desto
schwerer hat ist das virus sich weiter
zu verbreiten und meine hoffnung ist
dass die infektionszahlen sinken
ich kann es aber natürlich nicht
versprechen ich kann nicht in die köpfe
der menschen hineinschauen aber ich
denke schon dass viele verstanden haben
was wichtig ist in der kommenden zeit in
dieser zeit um die infektionszahlen
unter zu drücken jetzt die frage wie
weit sind wir denn am 10
januar und ich fürchte dass wir
deutschlandweit noch nicht bei einer
inzidenz von unter 50 pro 100000 pro
sieben tage halten sie das ende landeten
an dieser zahl da würde ich gerade noch
mal einen haken wollen 50 pro 100000
innerhalb von einer woche ist das nach
wie vor ein sinnvoller wert das sollte
eigentlich der höchste wert sein bei dem
eigentlich schon wieder einschränkungen
stattfinden sollten also das ziel sollte
sein die zahlen deutlich weiter
herunterzudrücken also ich würde eine
flasche sekt aufmachen wenn wie bei
einer instanz von deutlich unter 35 sind
das wäre für mich ein grund zu feiern
denn es ist ganz klar gezeigt von
verschiedenen modellieren dass es
deutlich leichter ist das
infektionsgeschehen gut unter kontrolle
zu halten wenn sie über einen niedrigen
incidents sind und ich spreche davon
unter 20 soweit wir 35 oder sogar 50
erreichen ist es eigentlich schon wieder
sehr kritisch und es kann umkippen und
die extra und wie können wir ein
exponentielles wachstum der infektion
nach oben sehen wenn wir aber das
infektionsgeschehen deutlich nach unten
drücken dann werden wir das deutlich
leichter stabil halten können und das
müssen wir noch viele monate bis genug
menschen geimpft sind dass wir wirklich
einen effekt durch die impfung auf das
infektionsgeschehen haben werden wenn
wir das gerade noch einmal
zusammenfassen was sie auch zum schluss
gesagt haben
vielleicht nochmal der ausblick eben auf
2.021 zunächst die frage wie sollen wir
uns verhalten was hilft wirklich um die
pandemie eben in den griff zu bekommen
das können sie vielleicht noch mal
kontakt kontakt auf den punkt bringen
und die zweite frage wäre dann in der
tat auch noch mal die wie viele leute
müssen sich denn impfen lassen
beziehungsweise müssen geimpft sein
damit diese herdenimmunität dann auch
für deutschland erreicht es ab der es
dann spürbar besser wirst ja also wir
haben ja mühevoll in diesem jahr gewisse
hygieneregeln gelernt und hygiene
konzepte erstellt und die müssen wir
weiterhin fortführen und dazu gehört
ganz oben das tragen eines mundschutzes
das ist weiterhin sehr sehr wichtig das
ganze kommende jahr 20 21 werden uns
wird uns der mund nasenschutz begleiten
dann aber auch weiterhin die anderen
regeln ein bisschen abstand halten wir
müssen räume gut lüften und wir müssen
uns an regeln halten wir müssen wenn wir
in quarantäne gehen sollen
tatsächlich in quarantäne gehen denn nur
so können die infektionsketten
unterbrechen und wie ich schon vorhin
gesagt habe wir müssen aufpassen dieses
virus kann sich verändern
es kann zu mutationen kommen und wenn
wir pech haben wird das video ist
dadurch deutlich besser
es kann vielleicht leichter übertragen
werden das kann man nicht wirklich
vorhersagen aber man muss mit dieser
möglichkeit rechnen und deshalb muss es
oberste priorität sein
das virus so weit wie möglich in schach
zu halten also die zahlen so niedrig wie
möglich zu halten und länder die diese
strategie gewählt haben wie zum beispiel
australien neuseeland und viele andere
asiatische länder
die waren sehr gut mit dieser strategie
und fangen natürlich jetzt auch an zu
impfen und dort floriert die wirtschaft
wieder und wir riskieren natürlich wenn
wir jetzt die zahl nicht genug sinkt ja
senken im januar
wenn wir da wieder lockern riskieren wir
natürlich dass wir in eine dritte welle
hineinlaufen und das sollten wir
vermeiden mit allem mit aller kraft die
wir haben sollten wir das versuchen zu
verhindern und wichtig ist dafür auch
dass unsere gesundheitsämter schneller
werden wir haben neue möglichkeiten wie
die antigen schnelltests die da auch
weiterhelfen können genau das noch mal
der blick auch auf die inzidenz das ist
ja auch im zusammenhang mit den
gesundheitsämtern immer wichtig dass die
zahlen eben nicht so hoch sind 50 war
der von ihnen angesprochene wert 35 pro
100000 wäre noch besser noch mal was
noch niedriger ja ja das wird das
allerbeste nach einer yougov umfrage das
wollte ich ihnen gerade auch noch
zukommen lassen im auftrag der deutschen
presse-agentur haben 65 prozent der
deutschen vor sich impfen zu lassen 65
prozent wären wir damit am ziel
also das ist schon mal richtig gut aber
das reicht noch nicht
ich würde schätzen dass wir eher bei 80
prozent landen sollten
und wenn wir jetzt aber schon 65 prozent
haben und es gibt 15 prozent die noch
unentschlossen ist dann tue ich alles
und die zu überzeugen dass die impfung
das bett
was wir tun können und ich würde
wirklich jedem der die möglichkeit hat
sich impfen zu lassen sehr ans herz
legen dass auch wahrzunehmen
das ist wirklich das beste was wir tun
können um krankheiten und todeszahlen
ein niedrig zu halten also noch mal
deutlicher appell sich impfen zu lassen
vielleicht noch mal eine allerletzte
frage es gibt ja auch immer wieder viel
kritik an der politik an der art und
weise wie eben die impfstrategie in
deutschland aussieht manche sagen werden
keine man würde sich immer nur von lokal
zu lokal bewegen teilen sie das hätten
sie anregungen dafür wie es im nächsten
jahr auf sagen wir mal der
administrativen ebene besser laufen
könnte
sie haben ihre strategie gesagt aber ich
glaube sie meinen die strategie der an
die bekämpfung sowohl man richtig also
in erster linie natürlich der pandemie
bekämpfung haben sie recht ja also die
impfstrategie ist die unterstütze ich es
ist wichtig dass wir die gruppen die am
stärksten betroffen sind von diesem
virus nun als erste impfen und das ist
gut und richtig so
und sie haben recht ich gehöre auch zu
denjenigen die kritisiert haben dass
unsere strategie der pandemie bekämpfung
nicht optimal ist ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass wir in diesem zweiten
lockdown erst gar nicht hinein geraten
dass wir in ein zu einem zeitpunkt wo
wir sehen das ist zu einem
exponentiellen wachstum bereits kommt
und das war schon deutlich früher zu
sehen ist das war ein september/oktober
ziemlich ersichtlich hätte mir gewünscht
dass wir da schon gehandelt hätten und
es war eigentlich auch klar kommuniziert
ab einer 50er incidents müssen wir
handeln aber leider ist das nicht
wirklich passiert es ist auch bei noch
deutlich höheren instanzen nicht viel
passiert und das ist nicht gut wir haben
ganz klare wissenschaftliche da und die
zeigen je früher und je konsequenter wir
handeln desto besser ist das für die
gesundheit für das soziale leben aber
auch für die wirtschaft
vielen dank das war nochmal klare worte
von professor melanie brinkmann auch
noch mal zur allgemeinen strategie eben
gegen die korona pandemie vielen dank
für die
das gespräch einen schönen tag noch an
sie und natürlich auch an euch liebe
user vielen dank fürs zuschauen für eure
fragen und auch kommentare ja das war
sozusagen der livestream zur ersten
impfung in deutschland in hamburg jetzt
in diesem fall naja nicht ganz die erste
aber zumindest die offizielle die für
die presse auch als solche freigegeben
war dankeschön dass sie dabei waren dass
ihr dabei wahrt und wir wünschen euch
noch einen schönen sonntag bis demnächst